two years after opposition leader Kem
Sokha was arrested jailed and then
placed under house arrest a Cambodian
Court has released him his daughter
who's also an influential member of the
band opposition Cambodian national
rescue party hopes this is just the
first step I hope that the chart against
him will be dropped and I hope that his
political rise along with the political
rise of my colleagues and myself will be
reinstated and there would be
negotiation between the two parties to
reinstate for example the space for
media rights space for civil society and
reinstate a real opposition party back
suka is still subject to severe
restrictions and the treason case
against him stands Madame have younger
going to Dorinda why we still have
questions about certain things mentioned
in the court order and we will ask the
court for clarification such as what
limitations are there on his freedom
what are the limitations on his
political freedom can he meet his
supporters what degree of freedom does
he have to meet with his supporters
analysts say sokka's release is a
tactical move by the cambodian
governments
it comes a day after Sam Rainsy who
co-founded the opposition party with
soccer arrived in the Malaysian capital
Kuala Lumpur from self-imposed exile in
France
he says he'll return to Cambodia to
challenge Prime Minister Hun Sen whose
ruled for more than three decades and on
Tuesday the European Union will publish
a report on the decline in democracy and
human rights in the country it's
threatened to withdraw Cambodia's terror
free status on goods entering the EU is
facing a very very serious situation he
is looking at the potentially damaging
actions by the EU against the major
industry in the country the garment
industry and he has to now step up and
show that he's prepared to make some
compromises on human rights issues if he
wants to maintain that a very important
EU economic status hunson controls the
National Assembly as well as the police
the army the courts and the media he's
ordered the arrest of dozens of
opposition activists in the last few
months this is the home of Kem Sokha
where he's been detained for more than a
year one of the demands of the European
Union is that not only should he be
freed from house arrest but the charges
against him should be dropped that
hasn't happened he's still awaiting
trial so while this is being seen as a
small step in the right direction the
opposition knows that little has changed
Wayne hey al-jazeera / Phnom Penh